>> THE OTHER LEGAL DAUNTING, FOR
HIS BUSINESSES.
THE NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL
SWEEPING 220 PAGE CIVIL LAWSUIT
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND THREE
OF HIS ADULT CHILDREN AND THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
LETITIA JAMES ACCUSING THE T
TRUMPS OF DECEIVING LENDERS IN A
STAGGERING FRAUD, THAT IS THE
WORD SHE USED.
SHE ARGUED IT LASTED OVER A
DECADE.
CHRIS CILLIZZA IS AT THE MAGIC
WALL TO WALK YOU THROUGH THE
STUNNING NUMBERS.
>> THEY ARE.
I WANT TO START BIG PICTURE.
WHY DID DONALD TRUMP DO THIS.
WELL IT WAS TO SECURE MORE FAVOR
ABLE LOANS.
TRUMP PARK AVENUE, ONE EVER HIS
PROPERTIES.
THIS IS A LOT OF RESIDENTIAL
APARTMENTS AND STUFF.
THE APPRAISED VALUE IN 2010,
$750,000.
THESE ARE RENT TROLLED.
CLAIMED VALUE, $50 MILLION.
I'M SAYING THAT IS ABOUT
$49 MILLION DIFFERENCE.
AND IN 2020.
APPRAISED VALUE $84.5 MILLION
AND TRUMP CLAIMED $130 MILLION.
SO 50-ISH DIFFERENCE.
AND 40 WALL STREET, APPRAISED
VALUE, AGAIN AN INDEPENDENT
APPRAISER SAID THIS PRORPERTY WS
WERTH 220 AND $240 MILLION AND
HE SAID THEY WORTH MORE AND I'M
GOING TO PUT THESE NUMBERS OUT
BECAUSE NOT BECAUSE I LEARNED TO
SUBTRACT BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
DELTA BETWEEN WHAT TRUMP CLAIMED
AND IT IT WAS APPRAISED TO BE
WORTH.
AND THIS ONE I FOUND
FASCINATING.
DONALD TRUMP USED TO LIVE IN
TRUMP TOWER.
HE CAME DOWN THE GOLDEN
ESCALATOR IN 2015.
THE APARTMENT IS 11,000 SQUARE
FEET, THAT IS STILL HUGE.
HE CLAIMED THAT THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE WAS 30,000 SQUARE FEET
AND HE CLAIMED THAT THE VALUE OF
JUST THAT APARTMENT, JUST THAT
ONE APARTMENT WAS $327 MILLION.
LETITIA JAMES, THE NEW YORK
STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID THAT
NO APARTMENT HAS EVER BEEN SOLD
IN NEW YORK CITY WHICH POPPY AS
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE VERY EXPENSIVE
APARTMENTS IN NEW YORK CITY, BUT
NO APARTMENT HAS EVER SOLD FOR
$327 MILLION EVER.
WHY DOES ALL OF THIS MATTER
OTHER THAN TO SAY DONALD TRUMP
IS FAR OFF WHEN HE ESTIMATES
WHAT THINGS ARE WORTH AND HE
USED THAT TO BUY TRUMP NATIONAL
DOR SAL AND THE TRUMP
INTERNATIONAL HOTEL AND CHICAGO
IN CHICAGO.
AND THEN THERE IS THIS.
I LIVE CLOSEST TO THE, THE TRUMP
OLD POST OFFICE AND HE MADE A
TRUMP HOTEL.
HE WOUND UP SELLING THIS
PROPERTY AT A PROFIT OF
$100 MILLION.
IT IS NOW A WALD YORVE ASTORIA,
SO HE OVERVIEWED THINGS AND TO
OBTAIN LOANS TO BUY OTHER THINGS
THAT HE MAKES MASSIVE PROFITS
ON.
THAT IS THE CORE OF THE CASE
THAT LETITIA JAMES LAID OUT.
THAT IS WHY YOU GET TO THE
$250 MILLION THAT SHE'S LOOKING
FOR RECOMPENSE.